[Musique]
qu'il soit gros petit important fut-il
chacun a déjà raconté un beau bar
et vous avez tous déjà certainement vu
ce type de détecteur de mensonges dans
les films mais aujourd'hui la
technologie pourrait bien rattraper la
fiction et révolutionner cette méthode
décrié puisque une entreprise chinoise
de téléphonie vient de déposer un brevet
pour détecter les mensonges grâce à la
caméra de nos smartphones ils vont aller
chercher la vérité dont vos yeux
l'appareil photo sera capable de déceler
le mouvement de nos pupilles pour
déterminer si l'on ment des tests
réalisés avec cet algorithme ont réussi
à détecter un mensonge dans 73% des cas
alors avez-vous peur de cette
technologie
[Musique]
la seule chose qui me fait peur moi et
je le dis vraiment je lis pour tout le
monde c'est que Raymond va être
difficilement joignable
dorénavant mais vous savez que déjà le
téléphone cyril est à l'origine de
nombreux divorces parce que on va aller
faire fouiller le téléphone c'est un
massage je me disais
on aurait vécu avant son téléphone son
smartphone mais les mecs frère tu
partais le matin ta femme
trop bien
c'est même pas au travail
mais c'est vrai je vais dormir
incroyable
moi je peux avoir un téléphone aucun
souci
[Rires]
vous voulez des techniques pour bien
fouiller un téléphone arrête tes
conneries photos supprimées message
archivé faut se calculatrice parce qu'il
y a des gens qui cachent un téléphone
avec la fausse calcule la technique que
personne ne sait les emoji fréquemment
utilisés si votre meuf ou votre mec
utilise régulièrement des aubergines et
qui les envoient pas à vous ces
problématique
il y a aussi sur la là tu te fais
écouter
[Applaudissements]
qui est un peu moins drôle mais quand je
suis à Dubaï dans les pays où tu vas me
dire j'amène ça tout le monde ne
s'intéressant de dire ou l'homosexualité
est interdite quand tu passes la douane
tu poses ton téléphone sur un espèce
d'engin comme ça et dedans si il y a des
photos d'hommes qui s'embrassent s'il y
a grinder s'il y a des trucs homosexuels
dedans on te met dans une pièce à côté
tu peux ne pas rentrer dans le pays donc
moi je suis allé une fois j'avais tout
nettoyer je peux dire que ça m'a pris du
temps donc faut enlever les tables les
machins les grinder tout ce qui pourrait
mais même si tu as été sur un lien oui
dans les toux et de le mettre comme ça
alors c'est très utile pour le
terrorisme et tout mais là c'est pour
l'homosexualité c'est ouf je te promets
que c'est vrai ça fait bizarre puis
quand il passe et qu'il se calme toi tu
es comme ça tu dis j'ai dû laisser
traînette
et merde les gens Francis
il faut savoir que quand on supprime des
photos sur son iPhone elles sont pas
supprimées en fait
elles sont elles sont seulement
invisibles et seulement on dit
l'ordinateur pour faire le téléphone
vous dit qu'il y a de la place
disponible pour d'autres photos mais
tant que vous rajoutez pas les photos
sur les enceintes photos elles sont pas
écrasées donc en fait sont toujours dans
le téléphone donc si vous souffrez
donc en fait si vous avez des images
vous avez le portable de votre mec entre
les mains on regarderait quoi en premier
les photos les messages quoi c'est quoi
ça vous avez 60 secondes
Jean-Marie toi non non moi je veux pas
me faire goûter parce que je suis
honnête et fidèle si tu as le téléphone
de ta femme tu regardes ton premier non
je rigole pas je regarde pas je fais
comme ça
les messages et les photos ça ça montre
exactement
je comprends que tu fouilles un peu dans
les téléphones
je suis pas là
pour cette application c'est que vu que
quand même la vie est courte et ben
grâce à cette application bah les gens
vont gagner du temps parce que moi ils
vont savoir quelle est la personne qui
est en face à côté du bonheur alors
justement
quand tu arrives et tu mets bis sur le
téléphone
à l'ancienne vite pour savoir le dernier
numéro appelé la chaise
là j'ai regardé rapidement je n'ai pas
l'emoji
je l'ai pas trouvé
le rouge à lèvres
faut être un mec pour envoyer le berger
non elle a rien compris mais elle a rien
compris
dans le téléphone de votre amoureuse
vous regarderiez quoi les photos les sms
je vais te dire moi j'ai confiance en
moi
toute la journée
j'étais très déçu une relation pas très
longtemps et Roger avec quelqu'un et je
lui ai dit bah je te passe mon ami et je
vais passer et je vais prendre une
douche il parlait et quand je suis
revenu m'a rendu le téléphone
et pendant 48 heures vous avez la gueule
ce qui pouvait pas me dire qu'il avait
un ananas tu vois et ça a craqué au
dîner et il avait lu un SMS c'est quoi
le SMS
c'était un garçon
c'est un garçon mais j'avais pas vu
depuis des années et elle est à l'époque
il m'avait dit non donc cette crème d'y
fantasme dans la tête et on s'était
retrouvé dans un restaurant et il
m'avait envoyé
j'aimerais bien que tu viennes dîner et
éventuellement qu'on baise
et là tu l'as fait ma réponse tu sais
moi j'ai pas très faim